♪ Make money, make, make money
♪ I'm the motherfuckin' Pope
♪ And I make, I make money
♪ I got a house made of
gold, and a city to match
♪ Bulletproof when I roll,
so don't play me like that
♪ Priceless art where I pee,
my loo's a Louvre like that
♪ Got your country's GDP
in the jewels on my hat
♪ Hustla of all hustlas
♪ Wanna see the proof
♪ Greatest artist of all time
♪ I got him paintin' my roof
♪ And for a low, low price
♪ I'll let you come and see
♪ Just exit through
the gift shop
♪ As you go to leave
♪ We accept all credit cards
♪ If you've no cash today
♪ Put a couple Pope
bobble-heads on layaway
♪ Buy as much as you want
♪ Buy as much as you're able
♪ Just don't let Jesus in
♪ 'Cause he'll start
flippin' tables
♪ Make money, make, make money
♪ He's the motherfuckin' Pope
♪ And he makes, he makes money
♪ Make money, make, make money
♪ He's the motherfuckin' Pope
♪ And he makes, he makes money
♪ Mmm, look at the ass on him
♪ He's got a face
that's an eight
♪ But an age of 10
♪ If a priest gets fresh
♪ And a complaint comes in
♪ Switch him to another city
♪ Then game on again
♪ 'Cause I got F-U money
♪ U's for Underage
♪ Stackin' paper higher than
♪ The rate of Africa's AIDS
♪ But no condoms, guys
♪ 'Cause God gets enraged
♪ Just keep praying
♪ And passing 'round
them offering plates
♪ Portfolios to uphold
♪ Full of government bonds
♪ You know those
things countries use
♪ To finance all of their bombs
♪ 'Cause God is love
♪ But he still invests
heavily in hate
♪ You seen the maintenance fees
♪ To maintain pearly gates
(girl crying)
Hey, girl, what's wrong?
- My grandmother just died.
- Aww, well I'm real
sorry to hear about that.
You know, it'd be a shame
if someone were to
stick her in a place
where she just burned
and burned forever.
You don't want that, do you?
- No.
- You know, I think I'm gonna
have to get some of my boys
to pray real, real hard
to make sure that
doesn't happen.
Don't you?
- Yes.
Yes, please.
Oh, thank you.
- Bitch, you got
my fuckin' money?
♪ Media, I run it
♪ Politicians, I own 'em
♪ Wars, I don't condone
♪ But I still bankroll 'em
♪ Wait, uh
♪ I mean allegedly
♪ 'Cause what goes
on in my ledger
♪ You're not allowed to see
♪ Not a man, woman, or child
♪ Nation or country
♪ Has the authority
♪ To stand up to me
♪ Because I got a little thing
called National Sovereignty
♪ It was awarded to me
♪ By this cat named Mussolini
♪ You remember, Hitler's buddy
♪ Back from World War II
♪ He said, "You didn't
see the Holocaust"
♪ I said, "Holo-who"
♪ I got a tax-free country
♪ Just for playin' along
♪ And when you're
this close to God
♪ Nothing you do is wrong
♪ Infallible
♪ Say it with a straight face
♪ That right, my God backs up
♪ Every single word that I say
♪ 'Cause he's not some old God
♪ Livin' up in the clouds
♪ He's here on
Earth, in my wallet
♪ And my bank accounts
♪ 'Cause I
♪ Make money, make, make money
♪ L. Ron Hubbard
♪ Pat Robertson
♪ Make money, make, make money
♪ Y'all some punk-ass bitches
♪ Y'all ain't even on my level
♪ Make money, make, make money
♪ And Dalai Lama
♪ What the fuck are you doing
♪ You gotta monetize
that shit, son
♪ I'm the motherfuckin' Pope
♪ And I make, I make money